it's my baby
it's my treasure it's my oxygen
it's my ground it's everything to me
with every minute that goes by the
distress deepens for richard okaragaya's
mother her 19 year old son
has now been missing for a week right
now i'm empty
there's nothing to look forward to it
has taken my breath away from
me richard lives with his parents in
west london where he was last seen
leaving the apartment block on cctv
the teenagers studying it at oxford
brooks university but had been shielding
at home because he has sickle cell
disease
which requires daily medication he needs
to
be found because he hasn't taken his
medication
he's under the hematology that's the
blood exchange
so he needs to come home richard walked
out of this store
last monday after telling his parents he
was going to see a friend they say it
was the first time in months he had left
the flat
and that all he had with him was his
phone it's been turned off
since then richard was reported missing
two days later
and since then friends and family have
launched a desperate search to find him
his parents say his disappearance is
totally out of character
and accused the police of not doing
enough to find him
claiming they didn't consider him high
risk until yesterday
i wish they had acted when i asked him
this child this boy has health
issues i think we would have gotten
somewhere by now
they let me down they let us then they
let richard down
they let him down completely richard has
no voice
the metropolitan police told sky news
that all available
resources are being utilized in the
search for richard
and that his family are being supported
by a dedicated officer
as they face an increasingly agonizing
wait for news
iva bennett sky news in westlawn